nessa então
e aí galera que assistiu planalto bom
vocês não aguento mais falar e gates no
topo da montanha e aí que não quer
deixar a galera tudo vocês um bem ou
menos do jeito que tá tudo bem vocês um
meio tá tudo ótimo
a não ser que não tivesse grávida de
cinco meses e um espinho gigante de deus
que quer meu funk é acompanhada de
verdade que acompanha pela muito tempo
sabe que eu sofro com essa desgraça eu
até entendo dessa listinha com que se
você sabe que o mundo é feito em
equilíbrio a pessoa tem é muito feia
desprovido um pouco de beleza o que
acontece e inteligente faz forma radical
com o patim vestibular vez na vida e que
ganhe o apartamento beleza e fica bonito
a pessoa quando é bonita demais saber o
que burra mas é bonita para o desfile e
fica famoso ganha dinheiro faz um curso
os aprendizes e inteligente é o que é
essencial o equilíbrio a pessoa não pode
bonito inteligente que se não só de
desvantagens tem que haver um equilíbrio
e eu vi que engraçado já vem graças ao
botão leva se uma poesia que vão botar
um espinho treino votação porque o som
apitar só o rapaz parece que caiu bem
muito né a vida é feita de equilíbrio em
que o ftc bota no lugar pega uma pessoa
inteligente bonita engraçada eu tô na
merda mesmo principais equilibrar com o
que vem muitos vão botar uma espinha
legal e gente esp é uma coisa engraçada
espinhel seguinte a espanhola saibam que
não estou aqui em casa ninguém está me
via ficam à flor da pele parece na pele
de bebê nossa como estou lindo nossa que
coisa linda pode ser cinco horas da
manhã até testemunha de jeová chega na
foto da sua casa a partir do momento que
você vir o trinco da cas e abre a porta
é a sair com espetáculos de juta e ela
brota assim do nada ea minha inspiração
a mostrada a rixa que aparecer e nem
todo mundo sabe você sabe que todo mundo
todo mundo tem um lado bom que tirar
foto gente vai fazer é self é quando
você reúne a
aí começa tudo no trabalho do gaeco meu
lado bom e tabela da franja melhor da
frança no meu lado bom de foto é esse
aqui não deve expressar e aqui eu não
posso tirar uma self que a espanha pode
fazer assim ó de vez em quando em modo
atizhar pedindo uma marca na foto não
sei se você sabe eu tenho um monte de
espinho pequenininha se espalha pelo
rosto é uma despesa que não dá pra
escrever que aparece tem uma vez por
semana ela se reúne às fazem amigas
amigas amigas vão tirar férias no meio
da coxa dele aqui é todo no bairro
carreira e da minha bochecha odin
orlando aqui da minha bochecha passou na
festa e não pode escrever que sabe se
espremer espinhas deixou marca no você
fica muito cheia de marcas mas tem vezes
que não aguento não agüentou a espera
espero essa distinção é do mt uma vez
que os pneus e tão grande tão grande que
veio lavar a minha noiva eu pensei em
levar no cartório registrar para quais
141 fé era menina uma criança ea mãe
tomando banho na guitarra pra mim ela
viu sangue viu com amor ela diz ainda
uma fala meu deus do céu meu filho não
me disse que eu ia ser algo engraçado ea
receita com espinha e aparece uma pessoa
que eu não sei de que planeta ela é ela
chega pra você falar assim paula que
espinha grande não dá vontade de dizer
vá lá é mesmo menino ainda bem que tu me
disse eu achei que era um câncer eu sei
que é a espinha na bahia está na minha
cara já teus que já sim mas porque não
tinha essas espinhas como se fosse uma
tangerina você descasca tirando final
porque sai gastou planejando já para
2015 para deixar a pele bem bonito ficam
pele bem bonito e sedosos porque hoje
você sabe que eu tenho essa pele lisinha
de boom do sindpd cagada mas no outono
acabou eu quero que você comente aqui
embaixo se você tem alguma coisa o seu
corpo que você queria mudar eu
particularmente quero mudar meu pé
o meu pé é muito feio o tema coisa que
queria mudar aquela coisa iria mudar seu
curso comenta aqui embaixo que você está
no facebook que você faz tem que curtir
se está no twitter pau que dá rt do
vídeo você vai está grávida forte de
divulgação do estado secult a foto ao
saber que você gostou e está no youtube
clique gostei do brother precisando
alguma coisa um toque não trabalha em
ice t e pé
baby